Your ideas sound brilliant in your head,
but do they confuse readers when you write
them down? Well, after 10 years as an
English professor and writing coach,
I've found that even the simplest
ideas can be made to sound complex,
and even the most complex ideas can be made
to sound simple. It's not actually your
ideas that confuse readers. It all comes
down to the way that you structure them.
So in this video, I'm going to show you the
coffee stain problem, which is why readers can
get so confused by your ideas even when they
ring clear in your own mind. Then I'm going
to give you the experience of readers as they
work their way through your text. And finally,
I'm going to show you three types of structure
in your writing: one that you're already using,
which you should probably stop using,
and two that you can start using today.
But first, why is it that we writers
fail to recognize the patterns in our
own writing that cause difficulty with
readers? Well, think about what happens
whenever you're trying to diagnose and fix
problems in your own writing. You've written
a draft and now you're looking it over.
Or maybe you have given it to a reader,
you've got some feedback, and now you're
going through giving some corrections to it.
And so what do you do here? Well, here's what you
think happens. All right. You take your draft,
and your draft has all these words on it. And
so you look at those words, and you know the
meaning of those words, and you're the one
who arranged those words in that order. And
so those words in that order give you a certain
meaning. And then you check. You say, "All right,
does this meaning that I interpret in this text
correspond to the meaning that I intend — the one
that I want to express?" And you say, "Aha, yes,
perfect. That's exactly what I want to express."
That's what many of us think is happening in the
proofreading and revision process. But what's
really happening here is what's called the coffee
stain problem. And here's why it fails readers.
So imagine this. You wake up one morning
and you're getting ready to write,
and you pour yourself a cup of coffee,
when suddenly a great idea strikes you.
And so you rush to your desk. You set down
your coffee cup. You reach for your pen,
and in all your excitement to start
writing, you knock over your coffee
cup. And so now coffee is staining the
paper that you're going to write on.
So although this paper has no words on it, that
stain — that particular shape, and the depth,
and the color, and everything — it will still
serve to remind you of the idea that you had
when you made that stain. The problem here is
when you hand this stained paper off to readers,
that stain would mean nothing to a reader,
because they weren't there in the room with
you when you had the idea. All they have is
a blank sheet of paper with a certain shape
and pattern of your coffee stain on it. In
other words, those patterns mean nothing to
your reader. They can't use it to reconstruct the
idea that you had whenever you created that stain.
The stain will always remind you
of the brilliant idea that you had,
but it will never remind readers, because they
weren't there with you when you had the idea.
So the point of this thought experiment
is really just to show the difficulty of
editing our own work. Like, when you look at
your own text, you're not actually reading it.
You're just remembering it. When you wrote
the text, you had an idea in your mind,
and then you chose a series of words in a
particular order in order to convey that idea.
So whenever you look at those words in that order
again, what you're trying to do is see whether
those words correspond to the idea that you had.
And of course they do, because you're the one who
chose the words. So in other words, what we call
proofreading and editing is not really reading
and interpretation. It's more about association
and remembering the ideas that you already had.
But if you can never stand outside yourself to
get beyond your own associations and experience
the text as your reader will, then how can
we ever edit our own work? How can you ever
predict whether a particular piece of
writing is going to work for readers?
Well, what you need to do is
learn the structures and the
structural locations where readers expect
to find particular pieces of information.
And you can experience this right now. So let me
show you how this works. I'm going
to read a series of numbers for you,
and what I'd like you to do is just predict
the next number in the series. That's it.
Now, I know, I know I'm breaking the fourth
wall here, and I'm actually reaching out and
asking you to do something, but I promise it'll
be worth it. So I'm going to read you six numbers,
and I'll give you a little pause, but I
recommend pausing the screen if you need
another chance. And what I'd like you to do
is just predict the next number in the series.
All right. So here's the first
series. 2, 3, 5, 7, 11, 13.
The next number in the series is 17.
All right, here's the next series. Predict
the last number. 2, 3, 5, 8, 13, 21.
The next number in the series is 34.
All right, last series. 2, 3, 5, 9, 4, 3.
The last number in the series is 2.
Now, in case you guessed any of those wrong
and you're looking for an explanation,
the first series was a series of prime
numbers. So that's 2, 3, 5, 7, 11, 13,
and the next prime number in that series is
17. The second set of numbers comes from the
Fibonacc— Fibon— Fibonacci, Fibonacci, Fibonacci.
I've never actually heard that word said, but I
think it's pronounced Fibonacci. The Fibonacci
series. So you take the two and the three and
you add them together and you get a five. And
then you take the three and the five together and
you add them together and you get an eight, so on
and so forth. And then it would be 13 + 21 is 34.
And now for that final series of numbers —
did you catch the last number? Once again,
it was 2, 3, 5, 9, 4, 3, 2. So
did you guess the two? Well,
if you did, then congratulations, because
you just guessed my mother's phone number.
But if that was your mother's phone number, then
the series would seem entirely coherent to you.
But to anybody from outside your head,
it's going to seem completely opaque. Now,
they're not just going to throw
up their hands and say, "Well,
I guess there's no pattern here." What
they're going to do is search for one,
and often provide one that you didn't intend.
When you write the way that you think, you are
writing according to that third sequence, which
is entirely coherent to you but opaque to readers.
So how can you make your writing more
coherent to readers? Is there some
universal structure that we can use, some
master prompt that we can give to AI? Well,
unfortunately not, because that's
not really how writing works.
And I know this firsthand, because recently
I went back and reread my master's thesis,
which I haven't looked at for about 10 years.
And at the time, I thought this was the greatest
thing that I had ever produced. It's something
I worked on endlessly. I would wake up early
before class and work on it, and I'd be working
on it all night, and it was one of these projects
where you forget to eat — you're working on
it so much. So I was really absorbed in this,
and by the time I handed it in, it was immaculate.
It was the most perfect thing I had ever written.
And of course, when I look it over now,
10 years later, quite embarrassed by it.
Not exactly because of the ideas, but actually
because of the way that the ideas are structured.
I thought things were structured so clearly.
I thought I had just nailed the organization.
But I look over it now, and there are parts of
it that are honestly incomprehensible to me.
But isn't that interesting? Because if coherence
is part of the text, then surely when I look over
this text, I would be like, "Well, there's
the coherence," right? It was coherent when
I wrote it 10 years ago. So why is it incoherent
now? It's the same text, but there's essentially
a different reader, because I've become a
different person. I've changed in that time.
In other words, coherence is not
a property of the text. Like,
we have this idea — which is wrong, but we have
this idea — that, you know, here's the writer,
and the writer is thinking and transcribing
that idea into text, and then that text gets
handed off to readers. And so if the writer
can make this text coherent and clear, then
the reader will look at that text and they will
perceive that coherence. And if that was true,
then you would be able to automate this to AI,
and you would be able to just read over your
text and fix it, to apply some templates or some
very kind of fixed patterns and make it coherent.
However, what the experience that I
had with my master's thesis shows is
that coherence doesn't really work this
way. It's more like this, where the idea
emerges through the relationship between the
writer, the reader, and the text. All these
three elements are in a kind of relationship
with each other, and the idea emerges from it.
And so when we talk about coherence, what
we're talking about is structure. And that
structure doesn't exist inside the text. It's not
in here. It's in the reader. And so the question
of coherence is a question of: how can we get
this reader to perceive structure in the text?
And you've already had the experience
of perceiving three different kinds
of structure. So what are those three kinds?
Well, the last kind that you experienced, with
my mother's phone number, was an experience of
private structure. You didn't have
any reference for the structure that
was organizing those three elements, and so
you provided one yourself. Maybe you took a
guess. Maybe you just got frustrated and threw
your hands up and said there is no structure.
But you couldn't perceive the structure, and
so the kind of structure-searching mechanism
in your brain posited one. And that's
essentially the coffee stain problem.
Now, more practically, in the context of writing,
that kind of structure — which is clear to the
writer and opaque to the reader — is what results
in a lot of metadiscourse. And that's why a lot
of academic prose, and just really a lot of,
like, bad writing, has a lot of these signposts,
where writers are kind of doing two jobs at
once. They're both expressing themselves and then
filling in all the logical gaps and explaining
to the reader how one idea follows from another.
And generally readers don't like this. It's not
to say you can never do this. This is writing.
You can do whatever you want. But just understand
that whenever your text is organized according to
your own associations, in the way that makes sense
to you, with a disregard of the reader, you're
either going to abandon the reader and they're
not going to be able to use your text, or, if you
want them to use your text, then you're going to
have to fill in all the associations and logical
connections that are apparent to you but opaque
to them. So it's not really a good way to go.
But now, the second kind of structure
that you experienced was represented
by the prime numbers, and that's what
we would call a contextual structure,
because it drew on your background information.
You came to the text knowing some basic things
about math. And whenever you looked at the text
and you saw those numbers in that sequence,
you recognized it — drawing on your background
information — from a certain kind of pattern.
And that, more practically in writing, would be
represented by something like genre awareness.
So all readers in nonfiction are going to
expect an introduction followed by some body
paragraphs. If you're writing a scientific
report, then you know that your readers are
going to expect an introduction, followed
by the methods, followed by the findings,
followed by the discussion. And that's not
given to them in the text. They're just drawing
on their background information from seeing
different versions of this kind of genre before.
But now, the third kind of structure that you
experienced was represented by the Fibonacci
sequence. And you perceived that structure
not from your own background knowledge. Like,
you might have not even known that
it was called the Fibonacci sequence,
and you certainly hadn't memorized all
the numbers in that sequence. You just
looked at the sequence itself, and the
pattern kind of emerged from the text.
And in your own writing, that's what we would call
a textual pattern. It's not one that the reader
requires any background knowledge to recognize.
It's one that's provided to them from the text.
And if you want a visual guide to four expert
patterns that readers will easily recognize
in your text, you can get my Visual Guide
to Expert Writing. It's four pages long,
and on this page I have four examples of textual
patterns with model texts taken from professional
prose. So you can grab that down below the
like button, or you can watch this video next,
because it's a deep dive into those four
textual patterns. So be sure to go check it out.